what's going on reject nation greg here
with these two
we're gonna watch the boys season two
finale today and yes
it took me eight episodes to realize
that background says season three on it
because it's the finale the reaction's
gonna be divided up into two parts
part one and part two this is part one
so part two should be uploaded right now
link at the top of the description box
link and pin comment
end screen card the whole shebang so
guys would really appreciate if you just
go ahead hit that like button for this
video if you end up enjoying it and as i
said at the beginning every one of these
can't show the whole thing on youtube
obviously full length reaction watch so
long so you sync up with the time coder
over at our patreon page over there we
cover so many tv shows like supernatural
doctor who we started up avatar the last
airbender and a whole
bunch of other tv shows too much to name
right now but if you like reaction
highlights and watch alongs i
guarantee you'll like it over there as
well last but not least want to give a
special thank you to eric over at nerd
chronic for editing this video for us
yet it's for so many awesome youtubers
like movie trivia shmod and a bunch of
other reactors
thank you eric for being you you sexy
mofo are you guys ready
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry that was me
i'm sorry
how to survive or super villain attacks
there's a super villain on your school
oh oh no you witness a violent display
of superpowers
what do you do your teacher should have
an authorized firearm oh my
this is america oh my god could you
imagine if i had a
firearm in my classroom
sprinkles the anxious one really with
the moist handshake
mom okay all right okay i
i don't care if you wear it i just want
you to have it
every millennial i love you i love you
too
what's going on they've lost their minds
the rpg releases an electromagnetic
personal impact
so that's stormfront thanks to starlight
we know that noir needs any [ __ ]
trainer how about it
it's not gonna work guys you know i
always say why do these coyote
all you need is an ar-15 and meet meep
no more
exactly see we're just going to shoot
right runner in the front
what if i testify escape convicts don't
have a ton of credibility
maybe i know someone who does give us
the day
maeve huey a train oh
yeah maybe the deep you didn't do this
i wish i had killed vogelbaum but no it
wasn't me
what it was giancarlo his edgar
maybe i mean he is pretty smart
especially for his kind
because oh i just i was like what does
she mean this kind
oh no i got it corporate ceos yeah yeah
there's no more premiers or paparazzi
or screaming fans or any of that dancing
monkey [ __ ] omelander loves that man
don't worry silly frederick had a
solution for everything
only the good young by billy joel's
playing guys oh goodness that's the
solution so just so you guys know
come on why is it always always because
he gave us the rights of the show
there's nothing wrong with billy joel
after the way that i treated you
you had every reason to give up what way
did she treat him
no no being angry about the things that
he did to her
you're speaking my language you need to
chill out
it is maeve you were right i was wrong i
could split that [ __ ] like dry firewood
big fan she kind of has a security
weaver vibe doesn't she
nate i need you to testify testify
why would i do that because things are
really
bad and i mean you've been talking this
whole season about taking them down you
know
i'm tired yeah tired
and sooner or later they're gonna hurt
someone you love my talking to you
she's my new favorite character look
all it took was a scene or two i can't
believe it
this is a worn out and we [ __ ] up
christ you didn't i save your [ __ ]
life
nothing ever changes or gets better
no
and i'm tired i can't stop trying maeve
take your [ __ ] twink and get the [ __ ]
out of here
he's not going to like that information
well he
can't exactly be seen with you with the
tower now
they work together no thanks
awful stuff our internal research bureau
shows an impressive
q rating he's an asset to what
what sort of commission is the church
getting these days forty percent
fifty sounds like you're open he is so
good dude he's
so good stormfront has problems with him
and at the moment belgium
what's the problem with they train your
internal research bureau
knows exactly what stormfront's problem
is with adrian
deep is still a win what's your play
the stormfront doesn't have problems
with edgar
or black noir
we've heard a lot about you
how's it going
[Laughter]
are you all close with billy yeah
we're his boys let's just say he ain't
really close to a lot of people
you know well except you of course
i'm close to him
my man i'm sorry
okay i have no right to ask you to help
me after what i said to you but
don't you worry all right i will find
your son
butcher's going to kill that kid oh
we'll kill you i think i think butcher's
going to kill ryan
no he wouldn't do that hi hi
we've been having a super fun time in
here golly
sorry we had to leave you all alone
dad's work can sometimes get pretty
crazy
he hasn't been alone i've been here i
got him all these dipping sauces
vod turn a bit of heroes
mom says that learning is a gift so
[Music]
that mama yours she sure does have some
cute little sayings do you think
learning is what's wrong with learning
is this man
i get it i would feel lonely too if i
was cooped up all day by myself
and this west elm death star
guys ashley's really trying her best
jesus ashley's low-key this season mvp
there's a little maestro
can't just walk in a planet
oh it's like planet hollywood can i get
a selfie
ask the boss kidding of course you can
of course kidding he has no control over
any of this
no i'm an [ __ ] for bitching about my
mom when you're just
way dead not dead
she's not i thought she was dead too
that's where billy joel comes from
mystery solved
i don't want to be like her oh
it's kind of clingy and pathetic
no oh no she it's fallen for you
keep it going
bring up more trauma from your past
no oh god no
we're even now [ __ ]
yeah i only killed your girlfriend
i was never here you got that [ __ ] on
your own yeah i'm back on the seven
story we walk back in so i need her
it's it's broken yes
agreed homeland is a friend
why would i betray him because you're a
ruthless bastard
very true that's hurtful you two
we play with the cards we're dealt it's
not ruthless
it's prices per share
maybe you should take a look in the
mirror i can't
lash out like some raging entitled
maniac
that's a white man's luxury oh
i will get rebecca and ryan somewhere
safe no
not becca becker stands for me oh that's
the whole point
that he's raised by his mother find him
a new [ __ ] mum
oh i'm taking my wife back and you call
me
a ruthless bastard you tell me where he
is
and i'll do the rest don't worry guys
everything's gonna be
gravy you are the strongest man in the
world and you're scared of a little boy
break him he's your blood just talk to
him
you don't know this little boy be the
man i know you are
are you going to grope him outside all
sun's watching
talk to your son talk to your son yeah
you like talking to yourself
let me jerk you off we're going to hell
all of us
i remember the first time i was in a
crowd probably didn't bother you
i was terrified they found me 80 miles
down the i-9
crying my little eyes out
you cry not now
anymore the people that raised me
uh were scared of me so they kept their
distance
and i had to figure it all out by myself
see
well you you don't have to go through
any of that
oh you're crying
you know everything else outside of that
it might be bad but homelander's an all
right dad when it calls for him
he tossed him off a roof yeah but he
learned
you ain't coming with us [ __ ] ryan
doesn't know you he'll never come to you
it's too dangerous and i ain't gonna
lose you he's my son
and i'm coming
i need you to promise me that you will
save him no matter what and you will get
him back to me
yeah of course totally this isn't just
about me right like he he can't grow up
like homelander you have to think of all
of the people out there that he would
and that's why he gonna kill the kid
i swear to you on lenny
i think he's gonna mess this up hey i'm
just gonna mess this up
that's it that's it keep going
a little more a little more you got it
sometimes it helps to imagine someone
you hate
oh god so try that i don't really hate
anyone
oh well that's not something we can
afford
oh my god under attack we are
so we have to hate guys want to hurt us
just because of what we look like
oh my gosh really
[ __ ] it's called white genocide oh my
god
oh my god
uh no
all right
all right
part one complete